the first vaccine doses are just the
beginning of a long and intricate
process to loosen the grip of the
pandemic on this country
our dr david agus will join us now with
a look at the big picture dr akas good
morning to you
let's talk about loosening that grip
beginning with
tamping down the death toll which uh
recently passed three thousand per day
how quickly will the vaccines begin to
make a difference there
you know over the next weeks we'll
vaccinate one to two percent of the us
population so it's a very small number
it's probably going to be toward the end
of the spring beginning of the summer
where we start to see the vaccine having
a significant impact
every week though we're going to save
lives every week we're going to protect
people which is critical
but it's going to take a while to get
toward that 70 to 80 percent hurt
immunity which we really require in this
country
and when you think about a return to
normalcy uh dr anthony fauci for example
was saying masked will probably
be worn through 2021 or near the end of
2021
define normalcy for me and when will we
meet it
so what we know with these vaccines is
is that in most people
at least we know is that it dramatically
lowers the virus level we don't know if
there's
not necessarily blocking asymptomatic
spread it probably does but we don't
know yet
but there's going to be 5 10 of people
who can get a mild cold and those people
are contagious so you need to wear a
mask until the numbers come dramatically
down
toward the end of the year and there'll
be a new normal the new normal is like
asian countries where when you're ill
you wear a mask and i hope that
continues
forever and that we can stop spread of
other
viral diseases also how are you feeling
about next summer a lot of people
kind of mentally are thinking well at
least by next summer there will be
movies there'll be baseball games
there'll be barbecues there'll be
birthday parties weddings will be back
do you anticipate the vaccine
opening up that closed world to
you us i think the announcement by live
nation a couple weeks ago is saying you
know if you come to our concerts
sometime in 2021 you have to have a
certificate that you had a vaccine so
there will be certain
privileges if you will to people who've
received a vaccine
there will be mass vaccinations
hopefully the rest of the most of the
country will be vaccinated
by april may june time frame and at that
point i think we're going to see some
loosening of the restrictions we'll
still be wearing masks we'll still be
associating distancing
but we're going to enable much more
gatherings and a more normal not a
normal but a more normal way of life
this summer
privileges tied to getting the vaccine
will certainly help motivate people who
are a little bit on the fence to get
that vaccine
i want to ask you a technical question
about the vaccine itself it's very
complicated going from out of the box
into the vial and then into a person's
arm there's an opportunity there for
error what concerns you the most
about how technically specific that
process is
well it's a tough process right i mean
heroes have stepped up over the last
four or five months
patients across the country tens of
thousands in the clinical trials
that went very smoothly now the rollout
happened yesterday 140 hospitals 400
plus today
and the problem is you're taking a
vaccine that is stored at minus 94
degrees fahrenheit
you were thawing it it has to be given
in a certain period of time while the
vaccine is still good
and then you have to watch the patient
as david just alluded to for 15 to 30
minutes
and make sure that there's no allergic
reaction so
in a sense it is a very complicated a
process in the uk when they did it
they expected to vaccinate three to four
thousand people a day
in the first week or so was hundreds a
day so
we're going to get it we're going to get
it right we're going to vaccinate the
whole country there may be
a few missteps in the beginning but it's
going to happen yeah
complicated process but here's a simple
result at least 95 percent
effective dr david agus thank you very
much